what can creators and entrepreneurs
learn from this massive statement by a
very smart CEO what Bob's doing here in
my opinion is a double win one he's
probably saving costs and he needs to do
that but this is a huge one
they're pulling back a Marvel in Star
Wars because is anybody else paying
attention it just feels like it's not as
special anymore there's so much [__]
[__] coming out of these two iconic
I mean iconic IPS and I think slowing it
down brings a little bit more of a
special aspect to it there's a real game
of supply and demand and when you find
something that works you want to squeeze
the [__] out of it and so for the people
making content or building a business
you keep going the same thing over and
over it gets diluted this is something
I've struggled with in my 20-year career
25-year career in the wine business
there was a sale type I would do over
over in my content you'd get into a
pattern you got to break [__] up and try
different things and they have tons of
other IP and you have tons of other
moves and subjects and things you could
be talking about